سنتحول الى ليث جعار
من ليث جعار من طول كرم ل الوقوف على ما
جرى هناك تحديدا
ليث بالفعل يعني الانفجارات في مدينه
طولكرم وتحديدا مخيم نور شمس لا تتوقف ولا
تهدا منذ اقتحام الاحتلال للمخيم وحتى هذه
اللحظه الاحتلال يركز في عملياته العسكريه
في هذه اللحظات في منطقه حي المنشيه الى
الشرق من المخيم حيث لا تزال اصوات
الانفجارات تسمع بين الفينه والاخرى بين
زقاق الحي والمخيم بالتزامن مع انتشار
اليات وعشرات الاليات العسكريه في ارجاء
متفرقه من مخيم نور شمس حيث لا يزال
الاحتلال يدفع بال التعزيزات العسكريه
باتجاه المخيم ويغلق كافه مداخل المخيم
ايه هناك حصار واسع من منطقه كتابه وايضا
منطقه ذنابه الى الجنوب من المخيم ومع
استمرار حصار الاليات العسكريه لمدخل
المخيم الرئيسي وايضا كافه المداخل تحديدا
منطقه المنشيه التي تشهد
انفجارات متتاليه وواسعه قبل قليل كتيبه
طول كرم التابعه لسرايا القدس اعلنت في
بيان لها عن استهدافها ل اليات الاحتلال
العسكريه وايضا لعدد من الجنود بعبوه
ناسفه في داخل حي المنشيه الاحتلال لا
يزال يدفع بهذه التعزيزات العسكريه باتجاه
المخيم والانفجارات حتى هذه اللحظه تتوالى
من عده انحاء من المخيم لكن الاحتلال يركز
تحديدا على حي المنشيه بالتزامن مع حصار
جبل النصر وايضا اي الطريق الرئيس الذي
يربط مدينه نابلس بمدينه طول كرم الاحتلال
ومذ السابع من اكتوبر شهدت او شهد مخيم
نور شمس اقتحامات عده من قبل الاحتلال و
تجريف وتدمير للبنى التحتيه شبكات الصرف
الصحي شبكات المياه ايضا ال يعني الطرقات
قام الاحتلال بتجريف بالكامل قبل حوالي
اسبوع من الان كان هناك اقتحام لمخيم نور
شمس حيث استمر لعده ساعات قام خلالها
الاحتلال بتدمير كافه البنى التحتيه ايضا
اقتحام لعدد من المنازل حالات من حاله من
الدمار داخل عدد من المنازل في المخيم
وانسحب الاحتلال انذاك صباحا بعد تدمير
البنى التحتيه بالكامل في المدخل الرئيسي
للمخيم في هذه الليله الاقتحام لا يزال
متواصل هناك تسجيل لعدد من الاقتحامات وا
حالات الاقتحام
والمداهمة بقوتها التدميريه الهائله وايضا
جرافه اخرى لازاله الحواجز والسواتر التي
وضعتها المقاومه في سبيل البدء او في سبيل
مواجهه الاقتحام وصد هذا العدوان مدينه
طولكرم الليله تشهد اقتحام واسع هناك
انتشار في مخيم او اقتحام ل ضاحيه شويكه
ايضا الى الشمال من مدينه طول كارم وايضا
اقتحام لبلده او حي ذ النابه الى الجنوب
من مدينه طول كن والتعزيزات العسكريه لا
تزال حتى هذه اللحظه تصل الى مخيم وسط كما
تحدثنا محاوله من قبل المقاومه لصد هذا
العدوان وهذا الاقتحام على مخيم نور شمس